وبالحديث عن بين الجديد فان مايكروسوفت
اطلقته بالاعتماد على تقنيه الذكاء
الاصطناعي التوليدي في سعي منها لسحب
البساط من تحت منافساتها جوجل في سوق
محركات البحث المحرك الجديد طور باستخدام
وكشف عن قبل عدد سنوات وتحديدا في 2009
يوفر محرك بينجا العديد من الميزات من
المنتجات الويب والفيديو والصور وخريطه
البحث والكثير من الفلاتر المتقدمه فضلا
عن القواميس وتتبع الطيران ولعل اهم ما
يوفر المحرك هو الدردشه التوليه المعتمده
على الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي تتوقع الشركه
ان تغري الموريننيين وتحقق الكثير من
المكاسب وتسعى مايكروسوفت لاستغلال
الدردشه توليد في الاعلانات عبر الروابط
الماجوره ضمن اجابات برنامج دردشه الخاص
بها بنك تشات بوت
[موسيقى]